[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] علاقتي بالقاهرة
تتغير باستمرار ، تشهد المدينة
تحولات مختلفة طوال الوقت الذي
يكسر فيه تايرا جميع القواعد ، اسمي
محمد الشهيد ، أنا أمين معارض
ومؤرخ معماري ، أنا أصلاً
من الإسكندرية. ما وجدته  عندما جئت إلى
هنا ، كان أن تايرا كانت بيئة
حضرية كثيفة وغنية في كثير من الأحيان ،
مما جعلها مهمة أكثر
لنفسي واستكشف المدينة بالفعل
وفهم كيف جاء هذا المكان عن
الصور النمطية التي
ربما تكون فكرة الفوضى حقيقة
أنه مكان صعب المناورة فيه ،
لكني أعتقد أن هناك الكثير في
المدينة ، فقد كان للقاهرة دائمًا معرض إبداعي للغاية تحت
التيار
الخفي بوليتان هو معرض ومتجر للتصميمات
في جاردن سيتي
يستلهمون حقًا من المدينة اليوم
والحياة اليومية ، لذلك هذا هو  فكرة
التكاثر في المنتجات المصغرة التي
تذكرنا في الحياة اليومية في القاهرة
من إبريق الماء الذي يتحول إلى
هزاز الملح والفلفل.  الحقيبة عبارة عن
خبز بيتا مثل هذا العنصر اليومي الأيقوني
في مصر ، وهو منحوتة عامة رمزية
تتيح للخطوط عبور الجسر الجديد الذي
أصبح بعد ذلك حملًا ، فهذه هي المنحوتات المفضلة لدي
، وكانت أعمال النحت في القاهرة
هي أول منحوتات عامة أقيمت
في سبعينيات القرن التاسع عشر ،
لذا فإن هذا الفن  يضيء نوع ديكو من البرج في الواقع
في الجزء العلوي وهو في الواقع
كيف يحدث ذلك في الشيء الحقيقي
الذي أحبه حقًا في كارا بوليتان هو
أنهم يقومون بالكثير من العمل
بأنفسهم ويبدأون الفكرة من
إبقاء العين مفتوحة بشكل أساسي على
المدينة ولمعرفة ما يمكن استعارته
منه
، أعتقد أن هذا الجهد لتغيير العلامة التجارية
ضروري للإحساس
بملكية المدينة ، فالماضي جزء منها ولكن
أيضًا الحاضر ، وهذا معًا
يجب أن يولد مستقبلًا ديناميكيًا أكثر إثارة للاهتمام
بالنسبة للمدينة.  مدينة